what up space fam goals in here for
anime up drawer and today I'm going to
be ranking the nine pillars from weakest
to strongest this is a pretty daunting
undertaking but I will take a crack at
it if we can get 5,000 likes I will do
it all demon Slayers ranked from weakest
to strongest where I'll talk about the
powerful non pillars like zani - time
zero and so on or I'll do every demon
ranked follow us on instagram at anime
outpour where you can now vote via
Instagram stories for which one you want
to see next if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell because if
you don't you will miss future Demon
Slayer videos keep in mind there will be
spoilers in this video you've been
warned now without further ado let's
jump into it in ninth place we have the
eighteen-year-old shinobu Cotrell the
insect pillar now keep in mind all these
characters are strong and skilled social
noble is not weak but I would rank her
below the other pillars in terms of
strength unlike most demon Slayers
Shinobu does not possess the physical
strength to cut off a demon's head
Shinobu can still fight though using her
speed and poison in her final battle
against upper moon to DOMA the demon
commented on how fashionable is he
complimented her speed and even said
that she might be the fastest pillar
he's met so far which is a huge
compliment she's killed many lesser
demons with her poison but her usual
poison is not very effective against
DOMA she had to sacrifice herself in
order to help defeat him she consumed
small amounts of demon poison over a
long period of time and eventually was
overflowing with it she purposely let
herself be consumed by DOMA in order to
poison him this eventually weakened him
enough for an auskey inconel to defeat
him so Shinobu was good at strategizing
but unfortunately her last strategy
included sacrificing her own life she
was definitely an entertaining character
and helped pull off one of the best
revenge moments in anime but in terms of
strength I have to put her below the
other pillars in eighth place we have
the 23 year old tank and usually the
former sound pillar unlike most of the
other pillars that will follow tengan
did not manifest the demon ser mark
which means he didn't get that
significant power upgrade that marked
once did
besides that even before we take marks
into account t'ankin had trouble dealing
with the weakest upper moon upper moon
sex Scutaro he needed a significant
amount of help from the others including
Roseanna to ignore skin that Zuko and
his wives to defeat GU taro and his
sister da ki it cost hanging a hand in
an eye in order to distract you total
long enough for ton zero to cut his head
off then tengan had to be saved by no
Zuko's flames which burn to poison out
of his system some of the following
pillars on this list as we shall see
could kill a stronger upper moon all by
themselves without losing any body parts
eager oh the snake pillar is not
impressed when he hears what happened
you go ask some what he was thinking
losing his arm and an eye to the weakest
upper moon you could assess all that he
doesn't even know how much help
tanga needed just to survive tengan says
he can't fight anymore and that he's
retiring at one point in the past one of
his wives was even talking about them
retreating from the front lines after
they defeated oper moon so this seemed
to be always the plan
tanking is strong but not that strong
compared to the other pillars he knows
that people like mu Ichiro and Gil May
are way more talented than he is vengan
wants to retire and spend more time with
his three beautiful wives and who can
blame him in seventh place we have the
19 year-old Mitsui who unlike the two
previously mentioned pillars is still an
active pillar meat studied the love
pillar awakens her Demon Slayer mark
while fighting against upper moon for
she's able to fight the powerful clone
of upper moon forehand Tengu while ton
judo Kenya and Ezra go hunt down and cut
the real body
not only does me truly distract the
powerful clone long enough for the
others to kill the original she even
does it without experiencing serious
injuries that's truly impressive and for
that reason I had to put me today with a
demon sear mark above Tang yet however
when it comes to the fight against mu
song maturity is the first of the
pillars fighting to get a serious injury
she can't keep up with the others and
has to be saved and take it to safety by
a guru who loves her still though meat
Sony is the strongest female pillar in
the series and it took the demon king of
Pop himself to strongest demon to
finally defeat her in 6th place we have
the 21 year old water pillar Gil Tomioka
although you could potentially argue
that he's stronger than my number 5 but
we'll get to that later
gu seemed incredibly strong near the
beginning of the series he took out
lower moon 5 rui the demon that was
giving Tantra and the circles so much
trouble like it was nothing however as
time went
dawn and poncho got stronger and we were
introduced to the other pillars do you
eventually stop seeming so strong
gee you in fact doesn't even think he
deserves to be the water pillar in his
view he never passed the final exam he
only survived because he was saved by
saboteur who pretty much single-handedly
defeated every demon on that mountain he
died protecting everyone so that
everyone just passed by default without
really doing anything
you just got injured by a demon near the
beginning and then passed without
killing even one demon he clearly wasn't
as talented as a beetle at this point
however you did get stronger after the
selection and he even created his own
new breath of water move called calm or
low it is not until the fight against
upper moon three Icaza that we finally
began to see what gyo is truly capable
of
during the fight against akazake use
demon stare mark awakened but he still
can match off Tesla's power in fact it
stun judo who ends up surpassing you at
least temporarily with his non self
state Octus I eventually dies after ton
zero cuts off his head
but only because aqus had decided that
it was his time to go later he would go
on to fight with the other pillars
against moves on meet suti is the first
to be taken out then Gill loses his
sword and needs to be helped out by Igor
Oh kill me and sana me he was strong but
in both the fight against our Casa and
the fight against Mouzon he's lag behind
his fellow fighters in fifth place
I had the twenty year old children Goku
the flame pillar it may seem weird to
you that I'd put Rango Koo who has not
manifested a demon slayer mark ahead of
you who has manifests a demon slayer
mark but I think that in Goku as of now
still deserves to go above Gil while GU
struggle against arc as I even though he
had a much stronger tangelos help and a
demon ser mark then Goku did amazingly
well without those things he even had
the added distraction of having to
protect the others who were too weak to
help at this point
akiza is consistently impressed by it
and Goku during their fight he praises
then Goku much more than he praises q
during their fight aqus comments on an
Goku's amazing speed his wonderful sword
technique and so on
he's so impressed at his strength that
he begs him throughout the fight to
become a demon because he thinks that it
would be such a waste if he died even
with a pierce gut then go
can muster quote-unquote unbelievable
power to use ah kazoos words off cuz I
was not strong enough to break free from
his grip so he has to sever his own arms
so that he can run away at this point
the Sun is coming up in akasa is not
willing to take his chances
as a result then goku succeeded in
protecting everyone else just like he
said he would yes when goku dies
Sookie you will likely surpass him
eventually if he keeps growing but the
way then Goku fought against an opponent
as strong as a casa without any help or
demon sir mark was truly remarkable
after an Goku is dead tanking comments
that even an Goku loss to an upper moon
which suggests he is among the strongest
pillars upper moons are usually expected
to be pillars they live for centuries
after all nonetheless iguras says he
can't believe that n Goku lost against
the third strongest upper moon it is
clear that even among the pillars then
goku was held in high regard in 4th
place i have the fourteen-year-old miss
pillar Muccino Tokita there is a reason
that Tang and thinks of MU each hero and
guillaume a first when he thinks of
demon Slayers with a lot of natural
talent at only 14 Muccino achieves an
insane level of power we talked about
how tengan struggled with upper wound 6
even though he had a lot of help
well Mui Chiu defeated the stronger
upper moon 5 completely on his own after
he awakens his demon ser mark he wrecks
him mu Ichiro is also instrumental in
the fight against the strongest
Oppermann kikuchi bo who is mu Ichiro's
ancestor at first Muccino can't do much
against Goku Shiva but later with Kiyomi
and Sun amis help Mui Chiu succeeds in
stabbing Kakashi Bo it is revealed that
he has access to a see-through world a
trait he shares with some of the
strongest demons errors in the series
like your Ichi Guillaume a and tangelo
furthermore he is the first pillar whose
blade turns red the color that
represents the power of the Sun and is
the super effective against demons he
sacrifices his life in the fight against
Goku she bow but it is the wound that
Muay children flick 'td that seems to
spread and destroy kakushi bow once and
for all
although kuku she will also start to
question himself and that played a role
in his eventual downfall to mutirão in
my view had more natural talent than
sana me but he died at the extremely
young age of 14 before he could fully
realize it keep in mind he was even
younger than
we chose life was cut short so early
while son and me has ample combat
experience and even continues to grow
chapter-by-chapter for this reason I
decide to put the wind pillar I had a mu
cheeto on this list so in third place we
have the 21 year old wind pillar sauna
me Sheena tsugawa when fighting against
sana me and Guillaume a cooker Siebel
noticed that these two are very skilled
even among the pillars sana me has
insane recovery abilities and manages to
survive even after receiving wounds that
would have killed pretty much anyone
else he even goes on to fight strong
opponents after receiving such serious
wounds he survived the fight against
Coco Chabot although he did have to be
saved by the rock pillar kill me on
occasion by the end of the fight Sun and
me had lost consciousness but was still
fighting against Mouzon sana me has been
keeping up with Guillaume a and E guru
as mentioned meet suti angie you were
the ones who lagged behind so far
perhaps sana me should even be second on
this list but I will tell you why I
placed eager to ahead of him in second
place I have a bond ie guru this may
shock you especially since in the data
book he is the physically weakest pillar
after Shinobu however there's a lot more
to overall strength than just muscles
agura has been keeping up with Molson's
attacks along with Yomi and Sunnah me he
was doing this before he even manifested
his demon slayer mark but as of chapter
189 Igor has just manifests at his Dima
ser mark and furthermore he's turned his
blade read like Mui Chino when he helped
defeat Goku she bow if he was keeping up
with the others before you can bet he's
going to be Opie now with his newly
manifested demon slayer mark which
should give him a significant power
upgrade mangakas usually save big power
upgrades for last to build anticipation
so it's likely that ego Rose will make
him very strong since he is the last
living pillar to manifest one plus he is
currently the only one with the red
sword and red swords are super effective
against demons beyond that he's fighting
in part for meet suti so the power of
love may even push it to further heights
it would be too early to put him above
gilma though who is recognized by all to
be the strongest pillar so in first
place as mentioned i have the 27 year
old rock pillar do me kimijima tantra
any knows he could immediately sense his
power
Coco Chabot knew
the strongest pillar even stronger than
Sun in me he is the one who turned the
tide in the battle against ku ku Shi Bo
and he even had time to help son of me
while he was fighting his strongest
upper moon he has access to the
see-through world and his weapon did
turn red after mu Ichiro's during the
battle against Goku Siebel but it is
back to normal right now however else
was last time the fact that II Gordo's
weapon turned red might mean that the
weapons of the other pillars may follow
suit and turn red - in the upcoming
chapters in short there is a reason that
Coco Shiro said he hadn't encountered
such a strong fighter like Yomi in the
last 300 years
not only was Guillaume a born with
natural talent he has honed his natural
gifts to their absolute peak according
to kakushi bo this giant among pillars
will no doubt be crucial in the fight
against moves on and that is it for this
video I feel really good about this list
and I hope you enjoyed it ranking
characters who haven't fought each other
is always a difficult undertaking so if
you guys disagree with this list that's
totally cool let me know how you would
rank the pillars in the comments
remember if we can get 5,000 likes on
this video I will do an all demon
slayers rank from weakest to strongest
where I'll talk about the powerful non
pillars like Tanja ronzonni - or I'll do
every demon ranked follow us on
Instagram and anime uproar where you can
now vote via Instagram stories for which
one you want to see next if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell because if
you don't you will miss future Demon
Slayer videos a special thank you goes
out to our patrons on patreon who help
us survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings ell dress fitted ala
beat Anatole cos ASCII alpha do angel
Cruz Rohan Kapoor Jessica Maloney and
team Sparky 65 and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Stephen and Radha a Lola not M
Matty Mac 239 makoto-kun the world
Steelers Tyson Kirino and the school bus
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon comm anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little
as one dollar if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits until next time see
you space cowboy
[Music]
you